en este vídeo vamos a hacer un repaso de
todas las cosas que hemos aprendido
hasta el momento acerca de ángulos
déjame empezar con lo siguiente aquí voy
a poner un puntito y voy a poner un
pequeño segmento de recta algo así y voy
a marcar este ángulo de acá el que da
toda la vuelta la primera cosa la
primera cosa que sabemos es que este
ángulo que da toda la vuelta que
corresponde a un círculo completo es de
360 grados 360 grados eso es algo muy
básico pero es muy útil saberse lo para
algunos problemas vale entonces esta es
la primer cosa vamos a la siguiente la
siguiente es un dibujo más o menos así
tenemos una recta
tenemos otra línea que sale de algún
punto de esta recta digamos algo de este
estilo y tenemos estos dos ángulos
déjame marcarlos en color rojo
tenemos este ángulo de acá y tenemos
este ángulo de acá y supongamos que
miden x y entonces si tenemos una
situación de este estilo donde dos
ángulos forman una recta decimos que x y
que son suplementarios x y que son son
suplementarios
varios y en este caso cuando tenemos dos
ángulos suplementarios la suma de sus
medidas es igual a 180 grados x g es
igual a 180 grados vale y la forma de
verlo es muy sencilla simplemente este
ángulo con este forman el ángulo de la
línea que es la mitad de los 360 grados
de acá y por eso da 180 grados muy bien
vamos a otro caso más a otro dibujo en
este dibujo ahora tenemos dos líneas
perpendiculares algo de este estilo ahí
va una y aquí va otra entonces que estas
dos líneas sean perpendiculares quiere
decir que este gran ángulo que abre a
ver si me sale bonito este gran ángulo
que abren es de 90 grados eso quiere
decir que las rectas sean
perpendiculares pero puede ser que
tengamos otra recta que pasa por ese
mismo vértice donde se cortan algo de
este estilo más o menos algo así vale
entonces en ese caso se forman dos
ángulos uno que está aquí arriba
a poner equis y uno que está aquí abajo
que le vamos a poner y bueno en este
caso en el que tenemos dos ángulos que
forman un ángulo de 90 grados
decimos que x y ya son complementarios
vale x y james y son complementarios
lee comentarios
complementarios muy bien y justo en este
caso tenemos que las medidas las medidas
de los ángulos suman 90 90 grados
excelente yo me confundo a veces entre
suplementarios y complementarios y la
forma de acordarme es que es un
suplementario suena como a super así
como que es más entonces por eso la suma
es más grande pero bueno esta es mi
forma de acordarme a lo mejor tú tienes
otra forma de acordarte la diferencia
entre suplementarios o complementarios o
simplemente puedes memorizarlo vale
bueno entonces ahí tenemos tres
herramientas todas estas son
herramientas después veremos cómo
utilizar esto en problemas por el
momento lo vamos a dar por hecho pero
bueno ahí tenemos estas tres de acá y
hay una cuarta que también es importante
y que tiene que ver con dos rectas que
se cortan pero no necesariamente en un
ángulo de 90 dos rectas más o menos algo
de este estilo
vale cuando tenemos dos rectas así se
forma un ángulo de este lado y otro
ángulo de este lado y resulta que esos
dos ángulos son iguales es decir si este
ángulo de acá voy a agarrar la
herramienta del lápiz si este ángulo de
acá mide x entonces este ángulo de acá
también mide x también mide x y de hecho
esto ya lo podemos demostrar mira vamos
a hacer lo siguiente déjame ponerle por
el momento que en vez de que está en
este me da x mide y entonces lo que
quiero hacer es mostrarte por qué x
siempre es igual a ye bueno para hacer
esto voy a tomar un ángulo auxiliar
estoy acá este de acá al cual le voy a
llamar z y vamos a hacer algunas cuentas
observa que x y z son ángulos
suplementarios porque los dos forman
esta recta forman esta recta de acá vale
entonces como forman esa recta y aquí se
forma un gran ángulo déjame marcarlo en
color amarillo un ángulo de acá
de 180 grados entonces tenemos que x z
voy a poner más para acá x x maceta es
igual a 180 grados 180 grados y de aquí
podemos obtener que z es igual a 180
grados menos x de manera similar tenemos
que ye y z son suplementarios porque una
vez más ahora forman este ángulo
ahora forman este ángulo y este el
ángulo corresponde a esta recta de acá
que hace un ángulo de 180 grados
entonces también tenemos que ya maceta
de maceta es igual a 180 grados y si
sustituimos este valor de z que
encontramos aquí abajo
tendríamos que che más 180 grados menos
x es igual a 180 grados y aquí podemos
simplificar un poco préstamos 180 grados
de los dos lados y sumamos x de los dos
lados y obtenemos que jeff es igual a
equis bueno aquí está una forma de
mostrar algo que es relativamente
sencillo verdad e incluso si uno toma
dos palitos y empieza a jugar pues uno
se da cuenta rápidamente que estos dos
ángulos son iguales pero bueno esto ya
es una demostración vale aunque estoy un
poco enredado ella es una demostración
que nos dice que este y éste siempre son
iguales entonces aquí tenemos cuatro
hechos básicos que vamos a utilizar a
cada rato cuando resolvamos problemas de
ángulos
uno es que el ángulo que corresponde a
una vuelta completa es de 360 grados
otro es esto que si tenemos dos ángulos
que forman una recta entonces les
llamamos suplementarios y la suma de sus
medidas es 180 grados el tercer hecho es
que si tenemos dos rectas
perpendiculares y dos ángulos dividen
ese ese ángulo de 90 grados entonces
esos ángulos les llamamos
complementarios y la suma de sus medidas
son 90 grados y finalmente tenemos que
si dos rectas cualesquiera se
intersectan entonces los ángulos
opuestos por el vértice son iguales
entonces si éste mide x estoy acá mide x
también y si éste mide z similarmente el
de arriba mide zeta mide z en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a platicar de más
herramientas vamos a platicar un poco
acerca de rectas paralelas y
transversales y una vez más es un nombre
sofisticado para un concepto que va a
saber que es bien sencillo